j'ai trouvé ça très drôle très amusant
et je le conseille à tout le monde très
bonne comédie très bon aller voir
vraiment aller voir d'urgence très
sympa tu vas pas croire ce que je vais
te dire qui est entré dans mon bureau
pas plus tard que hier Vanessa
best Vanessa best avec S un million de
dollars la plus belle gonzesse qu'on est
connu toi et moi oh la
oh il y a du monde ou quoi là un
mariage pas forcément bien engagé un
amour d'enfance qui ressurgit un
trentenaire en plein dilemme le point de
départ du premier film en tant que
réalisateur et scénariste de Manu paayet
je ne connais pas de film français qui
ait déjà évoqué cette fille cette star
du collège ou du lycée la fille dont
tout le monde était jaloux ou tout le
monde était
amoureux et qui est resté un peu dans
nos têtes à nous voilà moi je me
souviens encore de son évidemment de son
prénom et de son nom et à chaque fois
que je pose la question à un copain il
sort Caro Bertier quand je me suis rendu
compte que ça concernait un peu plus de
gens que que moi voilà je me suis dit ok
il faut qu'on en fasse un film il faut
qu'on en fasse une comédie romantique
une comédie romantique très appréciée du
public de l'UGC Skywest et laoréat du
dernier Grand Prix du Festival du Film
de Comédie de l'Alpe de aise au côté de
Manu paayet pour présenter le film ce
soir là son coréalisateur Rodolphe Loga
et sa future épouse à l'écran la
comédienne Anaïs de Moustier et un ami
pour le moins envahissant dans ce film
Jean-François carré j'aime beaucoup ce
film parce qu'il me ressemble beaucoup
parce qu'il me fait encore rire alors
que je l'ai vu vous imaginez un grand
nombre de fois mais que on y a
mis plein de répliqu qu'on adore avec
Romain et plein
d'acteurs qui nous qui nous font rire et
qui nous
émeuvent à l'intérieur arrête il y a pas
de signe tu es avec Juliette c'est elle
ta meuf vous êtes complémentaire à fond
refis la mousse là je vois tes
couilles mesdames et messieurs arrivé de
la plus belle fille de la soirée c'est
la
ça faut absolument que tu la baises bah
Juliette il en a de
Juliette situation amoureuse c'est
compliqué à laaffiche le 19 mars une
sortie délicate alors que sont annoncé
plusieurs comédies et que reste toujours
à l'affiche les Inconnus encore
dannyiboun pour le comédien Sam Carman
installé dans le département le choix
est en tout cas déjà fait il y a de la
vanne c'est drôle c'est tomber par terre
de drôlerie mais en plus il y a du cœur
et c'est bien joué quoi je sais que les
places sont chères tous les mercredis là
il y a plusieurs films français mais
celui-là Comé en ce moment donc ouais il
y a pas que des bonnes cellelà c'est une
bonne